hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to beam ng drive now if you
remember I played a game called next car
game which was kind of like this in that
it was a semi realistic and I say semi
because it's a little bit bouncy it was
good a car physics simulator game where
your only objective is to try to drive
responsibly like a normal adult but
everyone that plays the game just throws
their entire life savings of a vehicle
down a cliff to its own death and
destruction to roll into a crumpled hit
heap at the bottom of the hill and then
just hope for the best that and pray
that no one was inside that truck at the
time of its fall so with that being said
I'm gonna take this to its full
potential and by full potential I means
I'm gonna dick around until I can figure
out what the hell I'm supposed to do
with this game and the responsibility
that has befallen me does that make any
sense to anybody around no oh well hot
damn oh yeah this is definitely meant to
drive in the sand this is where it's
getting the most of its potential okay
I'm really picking up some speed now I'm
really clogging you know the best way to
keep a car living long lasting life is
to make sure as much sand gets into it
as possible so it can crap out a bunch
of pearls before it eventually dies okay
we're picking up now
we got a blazing speed it was I really
started the top of that mountain because
if so holy Dam I went fart now just like
my career
okay lost the mirror but I never really
needed that anyway cuz markiplier never
looks behind he's always looking forward
up this goddamn hill that eventually I'm
gonna climb to the top of everybody
ignore the fact that I'm really slowing
down and kind of getting bogged down in
my own ego I'm not talking about the car
anymore I'm talking about me
man this is getting it is reflecting a
lot of realities about my own person
okay and we're sliding backwards going
downhill yeah but at least we're going
down fast I'd rather crash and burn than
go a slow death here we go hey hey okay
this is a sturdy damn car and nailed it
look at that scenic underwater for some
goddamn reason
see I'm through the power of magic and
belief I have caused the car to float on
nothingness aren't I just the greatest
driver that ever was were how do i oh
yeah oh that's the stuff
oh yeah how do I start at the top of the
hill Oh turn my lights on well that's
almost what I wanted to do nope that's
not right hmm something at least the
suspension works man I'm gonna look good
at that car show whoop yeah okay if I
keep doing this am I just gonna start
flying something is happening what is
happening no idea what's going on whoa I
[ __ ] everything up well there's one
way to climb this hill I am an effective
driver everybody look at me yep
okay I just need to hold it down well
that's not as effective I don't know
what's happening now I need to go up
Marga Pilar only looks ahead why am I
going back down okay off we go then oh
look at me I'm freaking adorable this is
gonna
roll like a mother humper good thing I
got this trashcan behind me so I know
where to dump myself after I'm done with
this episode well never mind there goes
that much like the rest of everything
that I tried to do in my life it ran
away from me
oh well I'll never recover it again why
is this episode so sad and depressing
you ask well it's because whenever I
look at a car crashing and burning I can
only think of myself for some odd reason
I should probably talk to a therapist
about that oh well here I go tempting to
do this one more time the camera is
actually inverted on this one
why because other people drive on the
other side of the road and this is not
representative of anything that I'm
supposed to be doing in my life whoa
look a barrier let's hit that head-on
like everything else I do oh that felt
good I'm gonna hit it again because I'm
stupid and nope I can't because my wheel
got shunted to the front of my grill
uh-huh oh wow huh it seems that I'm
stuck spinning in a circle man I wish
that wasn't so analogous to everything
else that I'm doing in my life I could
have been an engineer at one point but
then I just gave up on my dreams boy
that makes me feel good glad I'm
shouting at a videogame that represents
everything that's gone wrong in my life
maybe if I just try real hard I can stop
going into another circle and then crash
into another barrier hop narrowly missed
that ha ha that would have been fun
fortunate if I'd actually hit something
oh look a sandwich
oh I tried I tried to do a simple task
and I ended up getting invariably stuck
boy yeah but I like read play skirt
well good it changed oh why why am I
still stuck even when I upgrade my
surroundings I still find myself jammed
in the same hole as before oh woe is me
looks are at the heart of everything
it's the circumstances in which you
arrive ha ha ha I think this is my spawn
point nope yep
I am boned me try this again this this
let's play took a turn I'll tell you
what spawn new please oh good
glad to see that I'm nearby where I
failed previously ok why did that happen
I don't understand cars why what the
hell something has gone horribly wrong
with the camera
oh god why oh god why this car drives
like a turd on wheels oh man
well I guess I'm not going anywhere
anymore ah can I just please not have to
deal with any of them why I just go two
steps and I spin out this is the world's
worst car I'm not even moving and it's
drifting all over the road
now take me away take me far away
and
at least I figured out how to turn my
lights on enough let's try the big truck
how can that possibly go wrong time to
have some more fun in this tunnel of
dude
ah [ __ ] that lasted a long time hmm as
long as anything else in my life I'm
sure I'm glad that this isn't too fast
because that would just be outrageous
and something that I wouldn't expect to
be fun I don't want to have fun on this
episode I want everyone to be so so well
there I go
mmm let's try this one thought this one
worked oh great thanks for cracking my
windshield right away
probably more stable when I Drive it in
Reverse why why are you why why is the
quiet why why why what are you what are
you Oh God death just pure unadulterated
death why why does the camera choose to
be such a [ __ ] ah yes again I am alone
just by myself in this agony of
nightmares Oh eternal pain and suffering
and loneliness that is my life I can't
wait to write poetry on the ways of
which I hate myself this is so sad when
Lisa I'm able to control little better
than I was before that is until I veer
off course and land in a field of greens
and
realism hey old canon why would I want
an old Canon in there can I really Drive
an old eye I can drive an old canon
shoot ball with button a oh boy well I'm
glad I had one shot and that was it sure
is fun can I just go ramming this into
random buildings if I can even control
it
I mean don't mind how this has a spirit
of its own and is somehow possessed
let's just try to ram into things huh oh
you're indestructible that's great I'm
out of here
I'm pretty sure it was best when I was
just able to throw myself off of a cliff
because at least I could do that
correctly everything else kind of went
awry alright let's see what I can throw
what else we got
how about a large hamster wheel I'm
gonna drive a fricken hamster wheel here
we go I'm driving apparently this is not
going as planned oh boy
okay yeah whoa not that whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa what did I just spawn I
have no idea haha that's somehow working
out better than anything I've done
before and it's just supposed to be a
spinning wheel of death of course the
county is a spinning wheel of death this
is gonna go spinning into the ocean and
somehow physics is causing all of this
to happen how lovely and a beautiful
really and now it's dead it's a UFO Oh
God aliens have finally invaded oh it's
beautiful and majestic Oh Lord look at
that oh no we're all doomed it's a sperm
ship Oh God
and back to it again I'm only gonna give
this one more try to be normal then I'm
gonna go the hell to sleep we're gonna
be normal
we're gonna get a nice car and we're
gonna throw it down
let's get an old style ah cop car and
there it is look at me I want to get a
lay of the land see which way is best oh
that's gorgeous
oh that's just gorgeous oh look at that
let's try this direction it's probably
just a good oh thank you camera for
changings like that
yep that doesn't look good all right
that'll buff out with a few waxes that's
okay don't worry
the insurance will cover that one are
you still going somehow oh you're good
at least you got perseverance along with
stupidity great combination an
unwillingness to give up or budge and
stupidity you could be in politics
huh it's going oddly smooth for me one
could say that I almost planned this out
to work perfectly probably not though
and scene that is beam ng drive I know
I'm not doing this correctly that's
apparent I don't know how to do this
game correctly and oddly enough it's my
first time playing it so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what I can and cannot do with this
game in the comments below I know
there's mods I know there's new maps I
know there's new vehicles I know there's
probably ways to tweak it so that the
camera doesn't do that and the physics
kind of work a little better than that
but otherwise this is pretty cool this
is a lot like next car game which has
been turned into something else and if
you haven't seen that video I'll put a
link in the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye hello goodbye yeah Nick where
are we going oh this is a bad idea